los volcanes salvadoreños una solución
de energía renovable para la minería de
bitcoins así lo plantea el gobierno
salvadoreño que busca utilizar la
electricidad generada por el vapor de
alta presión derivado del calor
subterráneo de los volcanes para
producir masivamente dicha cripto moneda
no vale más que el agua que la calienta
el poder de la tierra
las operaciones para la generación de
monedas digitales han sido fuertemente
criticadas por su alta huella de carbono
situación que el gobierno quiere
revertir a través de la energía
geotérmica aprovechando sus 23 volcanes
la iniciativa sigue siendo cuestionada
por muchos que afirman que si el país
logra proporcionar energía renovable a
bajos costos debería ir para las
familias salvadoreñas no para las
operaciones mineras de cripto monedas en
un país donde los precios de la
electricidad están por encima del
promedio mundial la minería de bitkom
obviamente es contraria al ambiente
porque hay una gran huella ecológica y
de carbono en el minado de víctor
principalmente por la generación de
gases de efecto invernadero en la
producción energética en septiembre el
gobierno de nadie porque él fue el
primero en el mundo en adoptar el
bitcoin como moneda de curso legal sin
embargo su implementación ha sido
inestable debido a su alta volatilidad y
a la defectuosa billetera digital que
creó el gobierno para las transacciones
en dicho país a lo que se le suma la
preocupación de que la moneda digital
incentive la actividad delictiva